throughout 2018 there were plenty of
major blockbusters and indie films alike
that were big hits with audiences
despite being panned by critics
don't let the negative reviews
discourage you from checking them out
here are a few films that deserve a
second look contrary to the critical
consensus the character venom first
appeared on the big screen in 2007
spider-man 3
but 2018 s venom gave viewers a new
origin story for the famous antihero
when Eddie Brock played by Tom Hardy he
tries to investigate the Life Foundation
for running dangerous human trials he
ends up accidentally bonding with an
alien slime in developing strange powers
even though venom has been criticized
for everything from its dialog to its
plot to its cinematography it's a fun
campy film that stands on its own the
technical details might be clunky and
the visuals might seem cliche but it's a
kind of trainwreck that you won't feel
guilty about sticking around to watch
[Music]
the nun is the fifth installment in the
conjuring franchise and turned out to be
the highest-grossing entry since the
original although fans of the series
flock to theaters to see it critics
didn't exactly hold it in high esteem
the nun was dismissed by some critics as
a series of jump-scares and other horror
tropes still there's a lot to like in
the film notably theis afar Myka and
fans will find that it's a welcome
addition to the franchise with familiar
themes on the struggle between good and
evil the spy who dumped me as a
refreshing action flick with a heavy
dose of female empowerment after Audrey
is unceremoniously dumped by her
boyfriend via text message she discovers
that he's secretly a CIA agent and now
he's gone missing
it's up to Audrey and her best friend
Morgan to figure out what's happened to
him and come to the rescue
most of the criticism for the spy who
dumped me focused on the film's refusal
to pin itself to one single genre still
there's nothing wrong with a little
creative genre bending and ultimately it
all comes together for a solidly
entertaining film this is how people get
shoved in the back of sketchy vans right
that makes this rather odd get in the
van
fantastic beast the crimes of
Grindelwald brings Eddie Redmayne back
to the big screen as nukes commander
unfortunately this new installment and
the fantastic beasts franchise struggled
as far as the critics were concerned in
the film Newt joins forces with Albus
Dumbledore as they race to stop the
infamous Dark Wizard grin devold from
establishing a worldwide wizard
supremacy the crimes of Grindelwald has
been criticized for packing too many
plot twists and tiny details for the
audience to keep track of and putting
the actual exciting magic on the back
burner still there's something to be
said for a film that demands your close
attention throughout if you want to
fully grasp the storyline and Tulley
Charlize Theron plays Marlowe a stressed
sleep-deprived mother of two with
another baby on the way when her brother
offers to pay for a night nanny to
lessen her load she eventually accepts
the new nanny's name is Tully and she
brings a new energy to Marlo's life
while some critics felt that their ins
performance was the only winning note in
this fell
Tulley strength lies in the fact that it
shows a realistic side of modern
motherhood that most movies are hesitant
to touch on Marlow might be exhausted
and overworked but she refuses to lose
her own identity in motherhood it's milk
Hema coke rampage stars Dwayne the rock
Johnson as a primatologist who has to
stop three giant rampaging monsters a
gorilla a wolf and a crocodile
as far as sci-fi monster movies go
rampage really isn't half bad taking the
video game premise into action movie
territory what could be more fun than
watching the rock fight giant monsters
although vulture called the film
aggressively dumb director Brad Payton
clearly knew what his target audience
wanted rampage was nominated for several
Teen Choice Awards the make follows a
group of scientists one of whom is
played by the incomparable Jason Statham
who unexpectedly run into a Megalodon
shark in the depths of the Pacific Ocean
the make isn't going for realism but
it's got plenty of moments that will
make you laugh and a few that will make
you shudder the film might have been
criticized as neither good enough nor
bad enough by variety but that didn't
stop plenty of eager viewers from
flooding to the cinema to see it the Meg
hits at sweet spot somewhere between
jaws and sharknado
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]